when is enough enough from a franchise
spy who's been going strong for more
than 60 years to an Android who had to
die more than once to finally be killed
off for good these actors couldn't wait
to sing their character Swan songs Ellen
Ripley is without a doubt one of the
most influential female protagonists in
all of Cinema long before Ray ignited a
lightsaber or Kat's everine competed in
the Hunger Games Ripley was using her
courage and wit to slay Xenomorphs
get away from her you all told
zagouri Weaver starred as Ripley in four
Alien films While most fans can agree
that the original alien and the Beloved
1986 sequel aliens are the two strongest
installments Alien 3 and Alien
Resurrection still have their place on
fans's movie shelves and Weaver's
continued presence is the thread that
holds them all together originally a
fifth film was set to be pinned by James
Cameron however once 2004's alien versus
Predator was announced by Fox Cameron
bailed on his work in progress telling
Ain't It Cool News in 2006 that he had
lost interest because he felt it would
kill the validity of the franchise
speaking to throngs of Xeno heads at the
London film in ComicCon in 2015 Weaver
explained how she was too put off from
any further involvement with the
franchise when Fox's crossover was
announced she said I heard that fox was
going to do Alien versus Predator which
depressed me because I was very proud of
the movie
though she was initially on board to
reprise her role in a proposed 2015
continuation helm by District 9 director
Neil Blom Camp the film was ultimately
cancelled and Weaver is more than fine
with it these days she explained to
Total film there are all kinds of
younger actors taking this kind of role
and there was an alien film that I
really wanted to do with Neil Blom camp
and we didn't get to do that but you
know that ship is sailed I'm very happy
doing what I'm doing I put in my time
and space as zword film seem to be
nearing their ner in the late 2000s
Along Came Zombie Land starring Woody
harelson Emma Stone and Jesse Eisenberg
the zomom managed to put yet another fun
spin on the sub genre's severed head it
also became a feather in haralson's
mid-career Resurgence as well as
catapulting Eisenberg and stone into the
spotlight but the movie's Undisputed
Cuda gross was a last minute celebrity
appearance by classic Ghostbuster star
Bill Murray God damn it Bill Murray
I had to get that out I don't mean to
gush now doubly Infamous for bringing
Deadpool to big screen life Zombie Land
co-writers Paul werick and Rhett Reese
explained to MTV that Patrick suy was
their first choice on a list of possible
cameos that stretched into the double
digits at one point they had nearly
secured Matthew MCC for the spot but he
fell out with only a few days until
production fortunately harson contacted
his pal Bill Murray at the last minute
originally cast as a living impaired
character Murray wasn't thrilled with
his role and asked if there was more he
could do also suggesting a few tweaks to
the part as a result the screenwriting
Duo revamped the script to include both
spoken and grown dialogue and they got
to turn Mr Badger into a zombie Nina Dov
starred as Elena Gilbert for the first
six seasons of The Vampire Diaries Elena
went through a lot on the show from
fighting off Supernatural entities to
turning into a vampire to dying a
whopping four times total Dobrev enjoyed
being on the show but by the end of
first six-year contract she was ready to
pursue other opportunities she told The
Hollywood Reporter in 2015 Anything For
the First Time The Unknown the fear
those are all emotions that are so
exciting ultimately I love that feeling
and I really want to feel that again
that's why I'm excited about this next
chapter I have no idea what's going to
happen and that means anything can
happen Elena's final death wasn't very
straightforward though first the evil
Kai placed a spell on her that meant she
would stay in a coma for as as long as
her best friend Bonnie was alive after
Bonnie died Elena would wake up
unchanged from the passage of time so in
the meantime she was put into a coffin
and stored in a mausoleum her death
wasn't explained until the series finale
when it's revealed that she and Damon
spent many years together until dying of
old age calpin may have only portrayed
Dr Lawrence cutner for a season and a
half of house but he made a big
impression on the audience during that
time cutner was extremely intelligent
but unlike Gregory House he was also
very kind I had a rough time in school
too maybe not like you but uh you know I
don't mean to compare our situations
it's easy to understand why fans were so
shocked and upset when cutner suddenly
died by Suicide without any clear
explanation Pin said he enjoyed working
on the show but also wanted to pursue a
career in politics after working on
Barack Obama's presidential campaign
Pinn was offered a job in the White
House and decided to change career paths
he told the Los Angeles Times in 2009 I
got to know the president and some of
the during the campaign and had
expressed interest in working there so
I'm going to be the associate director
in the White House Office of Public
liaison they do Outreach with the
American public and with different
organizations they are basically the
front door of the White House who could
forget Dr Derek Shepard the caring and
handsome neurosurgeon Patrick dimsey
played on Grey's Anatomy for 11 seasons
did you choose me for the surgery
because I sleck with you
[Applause]
yes McDreamy was one of the main reasons
viewers kept into the show so they were
devastated when he got into a car crash
and died in the hospital ultimately
though Dempsey's departure from the show
was for the best as there was a lot of
tension between him and the other cast
members in Lynette Rice's book How to
Save a Life The Inside Story of GRA
Anatomy executive producer James D
periot said there were HR issues it
wasn't sexual in any way dimsey sort of
was terrorizing the set some cast
members had all sorts of PTSD with them
he had this hold on the set where he
knew he could stop production and scare
people the book revealed that Dempsey
was burnt out from the long hours and
unpredictable schedule plus he wasn't
seeing eye to eye with Creator Shonda
rymes or co-star Ellen Pompeo all of
that led to him and rymes mutually
deciding it was time for him to exit the
show when asked why he left Grey's
Anatomy dimsey told Entertainment Weekly
in 2015 it just sort of evolved it just
kind of happened it really was something
that was kind of surprising that
unfolded and it just naturally came to
be which was pretty good I like the way
it all played out in season 3 of Gray's
Anatomy Kyler Lee joined the cast as
Meredith Gray's half sister Lexi the
sister's relationship was Rocky at times
but they eventually developed a strong
bond as they worked together in the
hospital then after 5 years on the show
Lee decided it was time to move on from
the role Lee told TV line in 2012
earlier this year I made the decision
that season 8 would be my last I met
with Shonda and we worked together to
give Lexi story appropriate closure
Rhymes explained on X formerly known as
Twitter that killing Lex off wasn't an
easy decision however after talking with
Lee they both knew it was time for the
character's journey to come to an end
Lee mostly wanted to leave the show to
spend more time with her family which
had been difficult because she worked
long hours and they lived across the
country she also thought that Lexi had
reached her full potential as a
character so there was no room for her
to grow as a result Lexi was killed off
in a dramatic plane
crash to
me Walkers claimed the lives of many
characters in The Walking Dead both
losing Dale was definitely a tough one
he was Brave and reliable and his win
aago was a safe haven that got the group
through some tough times Jeffrey deun
portrayed Dale from the pilot episode
until season 2 when a walker ripped open
his abdomen and Daryl put him out of his
suffering sorry
[Music]
brother Deon told Cinema blent Dale's
death was my decision I was Furious
about how showrunner Frank Darabont was
pushed out of the sh show I spent a week
not being able to take a full breath and
then I realized oh I can quit so I
called them and said it's a zombie show
kill me I don't want to do this anymore
it was an immense relief to me darabant
was the original showrunner for The
Walking Dead and a massive part of its
success nonetheless he was fired by AMC
in 2011 due to problems between him and
his colleagues since he and Deon had
collaborated on numerous projects over
the years deun was very loyal to him and
said he wasn't willing to be part of the
show after his departure
Rosita Espinosa went through so much
from the time she was introduced to The
Walking Dead in season 4 to her
heart-wrenching death in the series
finale I'm glad it was you in the
end she watched Negan murder people she
cared about deeply overcame being
terribly sick and of course escaped from
Walkers and living enemies more times
than we can count although Rosita could
have survived and gone on to appear in a
spin-off show ch chran sados wanted her
character to be killed off in the finale
producers obliged and gave Rosita a
heroic ending fighting off the undead to
save her daughter Coco she suffers a
fatal bite wound on her shoulder during
a 2022 interview with Entertainment
Weekly Sado said that the premise of the
show wasn't zombies it was family and
what you'll do for them it tugging at
your heartstrings was something that I
really fell in love with about the show
and I just really wanted people to have
that emotional experience in our finale
I know it sounds so dark but I feel like
the show we owed it to the fans to break
their hearts one last time she also
explained that the ending made sense for
a character who was fiercely loyal to
her loved ones and on a more personal
note she didn't want to deal with the
uncertainty of wondering whether or not
Rosita would appear in a spin-off the
character's death gave her a sense of
closure the pilot episode of fear of The
Walking Dead introduces us to Nick Clark
a troubled teen who struggles with drug
addiction the character played by Frank
Delan was a big part of the show until
he was shot and killed by a member of a
dangerous group of surviv survivors
called the vultures hilariously enough
Delan had said he wanted his character
to die in a ridiculous way such as
slipping on a banana peel and hitting
his head but the writers were having
none of it so why did the actor want to
leave the show Clark told Entertainment
Weekly in 2018 I had been doing it for 3
or 4 years the show has undergone many
changes in terms of different people in
charge all of this stuff and I just felt
like the beginning of season for kind of
felt like the end of an era with this
show and television is hard work and you
have to shoot a lot he went on to
elaborate I also missed Europe very much
I'm not American so after a while I get
quite homesick and all of those things I
also felt like we had achieved what
needed to be achieved in the first few
seasons so I thought it was time to keep
moving though Delan was ready to play
new characters he explained that leaving
the show was bittersweet since he would
miss the crew and the character he had
spent so much time portraying mlan
Stevenson played Henry Blake for the
first three seasons of mash the
laid-back character was a fan favorite
but that wasn't enough for Stevenson to
stay on the show he had a lot of screen
time when the series first started But
as time went on more scenes were given
to other characters Stevenson wasn't
happy about his character's diminishing
importance so despite the risks of
leaving such a popular series he decided
to move on and pursue other roles
producers could have ended Blake's
Journey on a light note since he was
honorably discharged and heading home
but in an unexpected move his plane is
shot down in the episode ainia Henry
there were no
survivors his death was so shocking that
producers received over a thousand
letters from Angry fans by today's
standards it might seem tame for a
character to die in a show that follows
Hospital staff during the Korean War but
this was
1975 Stevenson went on to appear in
shows like Hello Larry and dirty dancing
but he remains most well known for his
role on Mash bless you Henry Blake your
work here will never be
forgotten during the six years that
Julian Glover was in Game of Thrones his
character grandmeister pisel served
several Kings throughout his ten
pel pretended to be cowardly and feeble
but he was actually wise and
manipulative and used his abilities to
help House Lannister regardless of who
he was serving under you'd think that
Glover would love to continue being part
of such a successful show but that
wasn't the case he explained to IGN in
2019 I didn't want to do season 6
because I realized I was being
completely dismissed as a character
Cersei TI me off all the time and I
never had any comeback so that wasn't
any fun to play so I went to them and
said look I don't want to do this
anymore it's not interesting to go on
doing this and go on doing this and
what's going to happen to him though
Glover made it clear that he wanted to
leave the show producers weren't willing
to kill pel off right away so the actor
had to wait until the season 6 finale
pel perished when the former Meister
arranged an assassination in which the
little birds a group of child spies
stabbed him to death Glover earned
triple his usual salary while filming
the death scene and said he loved the
way it turned out so at least things
ended on a good note most of the the
main cast members on Miami Vice stayed
the same throughout the show's run but
John Deal's character detective Larry
Zito was killed off before the series
finale deal wanted it that way because
he didn't think there were any exciting
plans in store for zitto he said in a
1986 interview with South Florida Sun
Sentinel I didn't have much to do and it
was our third season and I didn't see
that changing they did give Michael tbot
and me an episode of Our Own in the
first season but it was a broad comedy
thing the two of us arguing over a woman
I guess that's the way they saw us
zitto ended up getting killed by Oswaldo
Guzman a drug Smuggler and gambler who
had his henchman inject zitto with a
lethal dose of drugs deal approved of
the character's dramatic death saying
that it was better than simply having
him quit the force he said he was a bit
worried that his acting career would
suffer from his decision to leave the
series but he went on to appear in many
other movies and shows including
Stargate and the shield Tasha Yar was
the chief security officer aboard the
USS Enterprise D and her bravery and
martial arts skills got her out of some
dangerous situations in 2012 Denise
Crosby said she was grateful to portray
Yar for so many episodes but didn't want
to keep doing the same thing for years
on in according to Star trek.com that's
why she has to be written off the show
after just one season leading Yar to
meet her sudden in unceremonious death
during a rescue mission on a desolate
Planet Yar and the rest of her team
confronted a hostile creature that
attacked her and sent her flying to her
death before she could land a single
blow despite her character's
underwhelming death rosby didn't regret
her decision to leave the series she
told trekmovie.com I was miserable I
couldn't wait to get off that show I was
dying this was not an overnight decision
it just scared the hell out of me that
this was what I was going to be doing
for the next X amount of years Crosby
said that she was initially drawn to the
role because the character had a lot of
depth but that most of that didn't make
it to the screen much to her
disappointment after a while she wanted
the chance to see what other acting
opportunities were out there for rather
than play it safe and then wonder what
could have been grent Spiner portrayed
the sentient Android data in many
installments of the Star Trek franchise
while the role boosted his acting career
it was a double-edged sword since
playing the same character for twoo long
can lead to getting typ cast on top of
that data doesn't age and Spiner felt it
was unrealistic to continue playing the
character for so long he explained to TV
Guide in 2020 there was just a finite
amount of time that I can actually play
data no matter what anyone says by 1994
Spiner was ready to move on to new
characters and didn't want to be in the
film Star Trek generation
but he ended up doing the movie after
some negotiating when he got the offer
to be in the 1998 film Star Trek
insurrection he still wasn't keen on
reprising the role of data so he called
the executive producer to suggest
killing him off at the end that idea was
shot down but Spiner finally got what he
wanted in the 2002 film Star Trek
Nemesis when data sacrificed himself to
save his friends and blow up the enemy
ship interestingly enough data's
Consciousness had been backed up
beforehand so he was later brought back
in a new body only to die for a second
time in the series Star Trek peard Data
and peard had a touching conversation in
which data asked to be put down so peard
fulfilled his and ultimately spiner's
wish I will do what you
ask thank you sir although Michelle
tractenberg has been in a lot of
light-hearted fun movies like Euro trip
in 17 again she Rose to prominence
playing Buffy sister Don in Buffy the
Vampire Slayer after after several years
on the show she got the chance to
portray sorority sister Melissa kit in
the 2006 remake of black Christmas but
she wasn't initially excited about doing
more work in the horror genre she only
agreed to be in the movie if her
character dies Melissa was originally
supposed to survive the massacre with a
murderous Agnes putting a bag over her
head and causing her to faint Agnes
would assume she was dead and continue
her Killing Spree then Melissa would
reappear at the end filmmakers were
willing to change the script so
tractenberg would sign on though so they
killed her character off in a uniquely
violent way after Agnes shoved the bag
over Melissa's head she broke free and
fought off the killer for a while then
Agnes threw a pair of ice skates at her
slicing the back of her head open before
Heisenberg faced off against the even
mannered drug kingpin Gustavo Fring and
Breaking Bad he had to deal with the
hot-headed and unpredictable Tuco
salamona
boo just kicks like a mule with his
wrapped the duct tape Tuco was supposed
to play a bigger role in the series but
actor Raymond Cruz didn't want to
continue playing the character he told
AMC I asked them to kill me honestly I
wasn't looking forward to coming back in
doing the part it's really difficult to
pull off they were like we want you to
come back and do eight more episodes and
I said no I'll do one more and that's it
you guys have to kill me they're like we
never heard of an actor that wanted to
die and I'm like you don't understand
this Parts really hard ultimately Tuco
met his in during a gunfight against DEA
agent Hank shider crw said he thought it
was fitting that Tuco died in a shootout
because he was so hard to kill that it
had to be done quickly and violently
jesselyn gillig was one of the original
cast members on Vikings and her
character Siggy was killed off in season
3 writer and series Creator Michael
Hurst had plans for the cunning and
resourceful character but those never
came to fruition because gilig wanted to
leave the show gilig told Entertainment
Weekly in 2015 at the end of season 2 I
had some family issues and living
overseas in Ireland just wasn't
conducive to me feeling like I could do
what I needed to do on behalf of my
family so I approached Michael who's an
incredibly compassionate man and he was
absolutely marvelous in understanding he
was disappointed which was flattering to
me but he understood many characters in
Vikings are violently killed during epic
battles but that's not what happened to
Siggy which made her death all the more
shocking she died in a very heroic and
tragic way saving two children from
drowning after they fell into a frozen
lake HST had suggested the story line to
gilig and she said she thought it was a
a beautiful way for Sig's journey to end
since it revealed her true character few
franchises have stood the test of time
like James Bond since Ian Fleming
introduced agent007 to the world in his
1953 novel the character has been in 27
movies across the span of 60 plus years
it might seem Unthinkable to kill off a
character that's the Cornerstone of such
a successful franchise but Daniel Craig
who started playing bond in the 2006
film Casino Royale knew he wanted the
character killed off just days after the
movie be premiered he thought it could
be a fresh start for both himself and
the franchise Craig told the New York
Times in 2022 if we kill Bond we can
begin again I think producer Barbara
broccoli thought that too but bless them
the studio MGM were like what are you
talking about are you out of your minds
there was reluctance so we had to do it
in secret really the movie's massive
success meant that Bond wouldn't be
killed off right away but Craig got his
wish in the 2021 film no time to die
Bond got infected by by Nanobots that
would kill his partner and daughter if
he touched them so he sacrificed himself
to keep them safe Greg said he was
satisfied with the film's ending since
Bon had finally found love and had a
child making his death tragic yet
meaningful she does have your
[Music]
eyes I
know for decades Jam Lee Curtis has
played Lori Strode one of the most
well-known final girls in the horror
genre but any horror fan knows that the
only thing scarier than the Halloween
franchise is its insanely complicated
timeline does Lori die in the 2002 film
Halloween resurrection yes is she still
alive by the end of the 2022 film
Halloween ends also yes the simple
explanation is that there are multiple
timelines in the franchise Lori survives
in some of them while she dies in others
let's explore one timeline in which she
died at the end of the 1998 movie
Halloween H2O 20 years later Lori
decapitates someone whom she thought to
be Michael but it turns out Michael did
a switch Ru and disguised an unfortunate
paramedic as himself Curtis couldn't
accept that Lori had killed an innocent
person so she insisted that her
character be killed off within the first
10 minutes of the next film filmmaker is
obliged and in Halloween resurrection
Michael chases Lori to the roof of a
building where he stabs her and throws
her off the
[Music]
Rooftop